foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
it's another piece of organized sense of
disgrace Matt Hancock finally slithers
into the Australian jungle as two
disgraced cabinet members back home
cling to their jobs it's British
politics facing a crisis of talent
and as Elon Musk Revolution continues to
cause Mayhem and Twitter can the
billionaire save Free Speech online a
last most infamous man on the internet
Andrew Tate
Plus in a jaw-dropping fluttering World
exclusive I'll talk to a protester I
actually agree with naked bird girl will
be here live naked in the studio
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan on sensitive for better or
worse and it's probably both this is the
age of the spectacular political
comeback Netanyahu faced scandal after
scandal in Israel now he's back for a
sixth term Brazil just re-elected
president Lula after 11 years at an
office put in two years in jail Boris
Johnson briefly terrified Britain was
sentenced a threat to his own second
coming and if Republicans get the
results they're predicting in today's
U.S midterm elections we may be on
course for the most remarkable comeback
of them all
I'm going to be making a very big
announcement on Tuesday
November 15th at Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Florida
I think we could probably guess what the
announcement will be it won't be that
he's going to a quiet retirement to play
golf a so-called Red Wave could also
mean there's no comeback in 2024 for
this guy
10 12 15. Bob stepping on them it's
black anyway
you can judge for yourself whether
that's a good thing a political
comebacks are not always spectacular
sometimes they're evidence of a total
absence of talent and The Grubby residue
you're left with when you scrape past
the bottom of the barrel
Cruella Braverman she's now become known
returned as British Home Secretary to
six days after being fired for sending
sensitive documents to her private email
account since then she lost what little
grip we had of our borders a sparked a
diplomatic incident with Albania and the
ghastly Gavin Williamson is back in the
cabinet after twice being fired and then
inexplicably getting knighted for his
services to being a failure
and now two short weeks into his latest
tenure he's disgraced the government yet
again with stories of bullying I get why
prime minister Rishi Suna bought them
back it's a big tent Politics uniting
the warring factions and conservative
party after years of chaos and big tents
are also for circuses and the best thing
he can do right now frankly his father
both and get on with fixing the country
there's one other failed disgrace to
universally despise British politician
we'd all hope we'd seen the back of and
it's the former Health secretary Matt
Hancock who tonight will crawl into the
I'm a celebrity jungler New South Wales
Australia precisely 10 190 miles away
from the very people he's supposed to
represent in West Suffolk this may well
be the age of the comeback but I think I
speak for the whole of Britain when I
say to Matt Hancock in your case we'll
make an exemption
well joining me now to talkative
International editor an author of Matt
Hancock's pandemic Diaries Isabel
oakshot former I'm a celebrity
contestant Christine Hamilton and the
Beast Mark Labette from the TV series
The Chase joins me now it's actually
fading away since even our last time I
saw you how are you yeah about eight
stone lighters eight stone light in what
period of time oh oh it's about the way
to do it properly over about five or six
years and how do you feel
hungry
[Laughter]
well anyone's gonna be hungry because
Matt Hancock is going to be hungry um I
want to start with Isabella shot on this
because I I wasn't aware you'd been the
co-author uh or presumably the main
author of his pandemic Diaries uh which
already will put you right into the
firing line when those get Unleashed on
the world
um but is there any defense you can put
up taking your co-author hat off for a
moment about him going into the jungle
to or himself around us as constituents
face the worst cost of living crisis in
history
well look peers I think that the hatred
and the pylon on Matt Hancock is out of
all proportion to anything he may or may
not have done in terms of the rules he
broke during the pandemic this is
somebody who gave the best part of 18
months of their life to trying their
level best to save lives now I have
plenty of disagreements actually with
his response to the pandemic and many of
the policies he pursued you and I peers
actually have a different view on this
and my view is certainly different to
Matt Hancock's on the merits of lockdown
but you know whether or not you agree
with how he handled the pandemic
response he was responsible for securing
the UK the vaccine ahead of most of the
rest of the world and I just feel that
the hatred that has been directed at him
is completely unfortunately how much he
gave let me respond I mean you I mean
honestly I've heard defending
indefensible but that is world-class
stuff there miss Oak shot because let me
let me represent the case for the
prosecution that he said in January uh
just before the pandemic began that we
were fully prepared as a country for the
pandemic after the first reports from
China had come out about a coronavirus
turned out we were uniquely ill-prepared
we had no PPE equipment which meant that
a lot of health workers and care workers
died we had no testing system which
meant we didn't know who the hell had it
at any given time so we sent elderly
people back from hospitals into Care
Homes where they died in their tens of
thousands we didn't close our borders at
all we let millions of people flood in
from countries where coronavirus was on
the Rampage
etc etc etc on vaccines it was Kate
Bingham who sorted out the vaccines not
Matt Hancock
when you put the case for me I'm sure
the pandemic Diaries will tell a
different story but I was living all
this all day and every day and I will be
fascinated to read his account of it but
the idea that somehow before there's
even been an inquiry we should be
letting him off the hook when the UK had
and this Remains the case more people
die in the UK from covid than any other
country in Europe that's just a
statistical fact well well peers peers
hang on a minute I'm not letting Matt
Hancock off the hook and I'm certainly
not here to defend his pandemic response
I'm here to talk about his role in the
jungle you'll have to wait for the book
which I'm sure you will find me ask you
this question
okay let me ask you this then let's turn
to the Jungle this is actually I'm
actually as exercised about this as I
was about his pandemic Antics because to
me he should at least have a good grades
having been fired for breaking his own
lockdown rules with a an affair inside
government buildings where they
literally devised the lockdown rules
having been fired from that and having
president as I say over a catastrophic
handling the pandemic certainly in the
first phase the idea that before was
even an inquiry twin in this stuff
before even the Embers have settled on
his shameful exit from government the
idea he then Pockets four hundred
thousand pounds to fly halfway well
literally across the world ten thousand
miles to Australia to go and make an
idiot of himself on either somebody get
me out of here while his constituents
back in West Suffolk are going through
the worst cost living crisis many of
them will have ever experienced I think
it's completely and utterly shameful how
dare he how dare he'd abrogate his duty
as a politician disappear off on the
taxpayer dime to Australia to promote
himself and pocket all this cash
seriously how day
well first of all I'm not Matt Hancock
so you'll have to wait and I'm sure
he'll respond to all of that but we
don't know how much he's earning from
this I'm sure it is
I'm sure it's a substantial amount we
also know that he's going to be giving a
great deal of that to charity we also
know that thanks to this government
he's going to be having to give
I don't know the answer to that is he's
going to have to give I well I'll tell
you this fears one thing I know for sure
is that the top tax rate is still 45p so
we know perfectly well that he's going
to be giving at least 45 of that to the
state so that's a form of Charity do me
a favor you know one thing I will I'm
sure you cannot say that was a great
thing because he's actually paying some
tax
all right look we're going to Christian
Hamilton who's now literally Christine
Hamilton is now covering her face with
her hands in disbelievable what you've
just heard uh Christine Hamilton your
response to miss Ocean's defense well
honestly I mean
commendable loyalty from Isabel because
she's doing a book with Matt Hancock but
I mean I have really heard it all now
because he's going to pay tax on it I
mean Heaven's alive let's leave aside
his covid record because frankly you've
covered that quite well let's just leave
that aside the man is a member of
parliament he is paid pretty handsomely
by most people's terms to be a member of
parliament we the taxpayer pay him his
constituents expect him to look after
their interests either at Westminster or
in Suffolk and as you say he's gone to
the other side of the world his argument
and I think it's fairly well established
that he is getting around 400 000 so
many various sources have confirmed it
but his argument for going in he says
because he wants to go to where the
people are and apparently 12 million
people
um was it 12 or 10
um tuned in last night I'm a celebrity
well that's obviously a lot more than
tune into yesterday in Parliament he
wants to talk about dyslexia and so
therefore he wants to go to the people
to talk about dyslexia has he ever
watched I'm a celebrity does he honestly
think that ITV are going to spend prime
time
giving his views on dyslexia
for the delectation of the British
hanging upside down in a question
exactly
the the problem is he's lost his
ministerial career he knows that's gone
he's lost his car he's lost his
uplifting salary and he seems to think
in my view that he's going to be able to
reinvent himself like Ed Balls did who
is now a National Treasure having done
strictly and some great television
programs but honestly Matt Hancock is
not Ed Balls people who know him say
he's actually quite likable
in my opinion uh let me go to let me go
to uh to Martin he's sitting here
patiently does he do all this it turns
out this is a bombshell development that
he's actually got your slot you were
being lined up for it well I might have
been I don't know I was one of the
people interviewed and they hadn't said
a word to me which tends to mean they're
probably keeping you on file just in
case we're both graduates of Exeter
College Oxford but it looks like he got
the gig and I didn't but I'll make a try
to defend the in defense come on then
what parliamentary rules has he broken
yeah we're all fed up that he's gone
there and he's drowsy reporting has he
actually broken any of the rules of
being an MP and I'd love it if the
speaker's officer yeah he has well has a
consistency apply the rules to everyone
yeah but I think what he's broken is
every moral rule which is that when you
are elected by the British public and
you earn 84 Grand a year to be a member
of parliament you down will turn up in
Parliament but that's the problem you
say the moral rules there have been MPS
who barely bothered they get turfed out
the next election but I think they're
not legally obliged but I think they're
shameful too but I think what's worse
about this is he's trousering all this
extra cash to go and take part in this
dumb reality show which of course a
little watch
um and it's got huge ratings but you
know it's it's to me profiting from the
blood Money of handling a pandemic
incredibly badly leading to the worst
death toll in Europe profiting blood
money again from the shame of leaving
the government you know when he was
caught breaking his own lockdown rules
lockdown rules which caused a lot of
other deaths by the way and continue to
do so because the lockdowns were so
Draconian you could have an argument
about it I supported them at the time as
being the only blunt instrument we had
till a vaccine came along but that's a
different argument but my point about it
is in the end this guy there are
millions of people in this country
really suffering on the breadline right
now really suffering they will want help
from their MP and their MP is
gallivanting out in Australia taking
part in stupid games for 400 Grand well
they're all left on their own that's my
problem with it no I agree morally it
stinks I'm just saying from the legal
point of view has he actually failed his
legal Duty there's one thing I think
people haven't thought of here you're
one of the 10 other people or whatever
is in the jungle what happens you see
Matt Hancock turn up and you've lost
loved ones in the pandemic right well we
know Charlotte we know Charlene White
House
I might have been tempted to knock his
lights out we know she got very tearful
on air talking about I think it was one
a relative or yes a good friend who died
of covid right there will be millions of
people watching who feel that way I know
so many people who lost loved ones I
know people who in the lockdown I had a
very good school friend of mine who said
goodbye to her mother on FaceTime on a
mobile phone because she wasn't allowed
to go to the care home which had covid
ripped through it because people were
sent back from hospital without being
tested that was on Matt Hancock so there
will be people absolutely spewing blood
about this and I that's my problem with
it I will always give the government a
little bit of leeway because in March
2020 none of us knew what was coming
they were trying their best under
difficult circumstances what we probably
don't take into account is that half the
government were going down with this
disease at the moment including the
Prime Minister you would have had
someone my response to that is but I'd
agree with you after that well in 2016
we had a pandemic exercise yeah called
exercise sickness yes and it was a
three-day exercise in which it planned
the country supposedly for a pandemic
and they made a number of
recommendations based on the fact there
was no BBE no testing system and so on
none of it got acted on do you know who
was in charge you know who was in charge
uh Jeremy Hunt who's the new chance of
executive he was Health secretary now
it's a breaking news has just come in as
we're talking about hapless members of
governments Gavin Williamson has
resigned so they obviously listen to my
monologue and they've got rid of him uh
Gavin Williams Williamson has gone
that's the third time he's had to leave
the government it's Rishi sunak's first
loss of a cabinet minister frankly Rishi
if you're watching you brought this on
yourself why would you bring back Gavin
Williamson who by General consent was
utterly hopeless why would you put him
back in the government only for this to
happen apparently William says he's
becoming a distraction you think you
think
absolutely ridiculous he was brought
back shameful he's now had to resign and
we've got Matt Hancock in the jungle is
anybody left has anyone left to
Defenders Isabella Before I Let You Go
your thoughts on Gavin Williamson
well I didn't think that the text
message exchange was reason enough for
him to resign because we've all had
spats with colleagues haven't we but
clearly there was more to it but peers I
just want a challenge your long rant
there blaming all the ills of the
pandemic on Matt Hancock and you seem to
be fixating with the money that he's
supposedly receiving for this stint in
the jungle I will say in Matt's defense
I have rarely met anyone as hard working
and I don't think that his constituents
are going to lose out long run as a
result of him being how much are you
both getting of the pandemic or not how
much are you getting for the book I'm
sorry how much are you both getting for
the book I've had not a penny I have had
not a penny
that's part
I actually do you know what appears I
have spent pretty much the whole year
working on it for not one penny that may
surprise you will that still be the case
when you sell the rights
well I I would very much hope that I end
up recouping some of my losses let's put
it that way but this is not a book I
have done for the money it's a book that
I've done for the uh journalistic story
you know me peers I like to be you know
I didn't think there was any jobs worse
than being Madonna's toy boy lover but I
think being Matt Hancock's Defender is
right up there Oakshire I've got to be
honest
wait till you read the wait till you
read the book and then work it out
waiting with baited breath thank you for
joining us for a month yeah are you
still in Australia no you're back here
don't you
I'm back here and certainly nowhere near
a jungle unfortunately just the
political one well we appreciate you
joining us Christy thank you very much
for joining us Mark great to see you uh
tell me about Chase is anything coming
for Christmas Yes uh we've got uh two
Christmas shows the Glamorous one and we
are I've heard rumors you might be in a
ladies underwear is that right
chance to be fine
I can't possibly comment you'll have to
tune in on Christmas day it's a
brilliant show uh I went on it and it
was uh well it was extremely
excruciating but I did enjoy the
experience in a weird selfie this was a
bit of a clip here look oh it was
Nightmare
yeah I mean you were I mean you look at
the top of you look you look like a
beast and you've lost so much weight I'm
not sure the Beast tag really applies oh
I'm still bigger than most people but
unfortunately for you the the one thing
we learned from that Susanna's way
smarter I'm sorry about that see on
General Knowledge I tell you she was I
didn't have my question anytime she
knows I always said she was like the
school SWOT Susanna
um anyway great to see you thanks for
coming much appreciate it still be
coming uncensored uh she's dared to Bear
all for her cause which is birds and
she's here in the studio naked bird girl
will be live here she is wearing barely
a stitch of clothing uh and I'm fully
supportive of this kind of protest and
we'll discuss why in the in a few
moments
suspense accounts for parodying him is
he still demand to save Free Speech
online well one man knows I think I'll
do about being banned on social media is
Andrew Tate he's back he's uncensored
again and we're giving us his views on
Elon Musk and what's going on Twitter
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook and sensor well
big breaking news in the last few
minutes uh sir still sounds Preposterous
Gavin Williamson knighted for services
to resigning and being fired has now
been fired again from government uh let
us just come out from saying he refutes
of course all allegations of being a
nasty little bully but he's gone anyway
because he's become a distraction with
Kate McCann uh our political Guru joins
me live now now from the heart of
Westminster there which is probably
exploding with excitement it's okay I
mean this is the least surprising news
of the entire Millennium the more
surprising aspect of all this is what on
Earth Rishi sune was doing bringing
somebody so damaged with such a record
of failure and ignominious departures
from government back into his first
government only for this to then blow up
today yeah and I think that was the
question that's been swirling around
Westminster this afternoon speaking to
people there you know trying to
understand whether this was one of those
issues that was going to run and run the
thing that kept coming back time and
again was that it's the question of
Rishi Cena's political judgment and
people kept pointing to different things
that he'd done during his time not just
as prime minister but also as Chancellor
II his reaction for example to some of
the allegations about his own family and
the way he dealt with those that people
were saying well maybe he's just not
quite up to it in terms of the politics
and suggesting that he has six months to
prove those doubters wrong I mean I
think from this letter it's very clear
that Gavin Williamson feels fairly
aggrieved by the fact that he's had to
resign as you pointed out their peers he
says he refutes the characterization of
these claims but recognizes that he's
becoming a distraction he also says
interestingly that he has apologized to
the recipient of the messages he's
talking there about Wendy Morton the
former conservative Chief whip until
very recently also a position that he
once held she said over the last couple
of days through allies not directly that
she felt pretty fed up that he hadn't
directly apologized and that actually
she'd now referred those text messages
to an independent Watchdog there were
three by the end of today investigations
into Gavin Williamson's conduct that one
one from the conservative party and
number 10 was also looking into other
serious allegations which emerged
yesterday in the Guardian newspaper and
I think it was fair to say that his time
had come there was a question about
whether or not Gavin Williamson would be
allowed to stay until those
investigations were over but clearly
tonight that's not the case someone at
some point has stepped in if it was
Rishi sunak perhaps the message had got
through that people were questioning his
political judgment yeah but next time he
should just call me Reggie sunac and ask
me is this a good idea appears it'd be a
bit like the conversation about suela
bravaman no these are not good ideas you
don't bring somebody back after six days
after they're being fired and you never
bring back someone like Gavin Williamson
because he's obviously completely
useless
um anyway I would imagine the concussion
to this will be pretty significant not
just for Williamson who's gone or for
the government but also for Rishi sunnak
himself big test of his leadership so
early into his tenure he's supposed to
be steadying the ship calming everything
down no more dramas and here we are just
a few weeks into his tenure with a
spectacular sacking of one of his first
cabinet members
yeah and absolutely terrible timing
peers I mean we're going into prime
minister's questions tomorrow it's only
I think I wish you see next third outing
against the labor leader Zakir starmer
and if you were labor tonight you'd be
rubbing your hands together you've got
an absolute wealth of opportunities to
push the prime minister in difficult
directions this is going to be top of
your agenda what on Earth went wrong
with Gavin Williamson and why did you
let this drag out over the weekend but
today there was a debate in Parliament
over Sue Ella bravaman her conduct
whether she ought to be home secretary
really big questions about her
appointment you've got what's happening
at manston with immigration you know
illegal migrants crossing the channel
and then being essentially left in tents
for weeks on end there's a question of
why he did or didn't want to go to cop27
and whether that speech was long enough
I mean there are lots and lots of
questions for Rishi Cena and the problem
for the government at the moment is that
they're pretty hamstrung about what they
can actually say and so we get to the
budget in just under two weeks time when
they will reveal some really difficult
called choices I mean you've seen over
the last couple of days potentially
trying to soften that blow expectation
management about the size of the black
hole 50 60 billion pounds and then a
clear message in the times that actually
those who are most vulnerable will be
protected but that doesn't mean things
won't be hard so Richardson is looking
down a tunnel at the end of it is a
really difficult budget he's got to
deliver with his Chancellor and suck up
quite hard headlines this is the last
thing he needs right now no but the one
thing you talk about looking at things
he was probably watching my show because
at 8 00 p.m tonight I called for Gavin
Williamson to be fired and at 8 11 p.m
he was fired and I'm doing the math here
at Kate McCann and as usual it looks
like the corridors of Power are
listening to me
well appears maybe they're in the market
for uh you know an extra director of
comms would you consider it
I would never demean myself at such a
lowly level the tagline position in the
Lords PM for PM still has the most
majestic ring to it and you know what if
I do become Prime Minister you can come
and be my director of comms my little
Alistair Campbell
little your little Alistair Campbell or
your little eye compared to others to
gamble he was he's huge
consider it I'll consider it uh big
breaking news anyway you can be very
busy again Kate uh thanks for joining
the show we appreciate it Elon musk's
tenure at Twitter has begun explosively
with mass layoffs and hotly debated
plans to charge users for verification
this is about to restore free speech to
the platform's most divided opinion the
site so far not restored any high
profile banned accounts like Donald
Trump's and so on in fact Twitter
suspended several celebrities for
impersonating musk although that was an
existing rule that you couldn't do that
but joining me now is Andrew Tate his
videos have been viewed billions of
Times online but he's been banned from
pretty much every mainstream social
media platform including Twitter uh
Andrew welcome back to Piers Morgan
uncensored um your take on this I think
it's quite interesting because you've
been a victim of being a victims the
right word but you've been removed from
social media platforms for your opinions
um Elon Musk has dedicated himself he
says to restoring Free Speech uh do you
think that's going to include you for
example
I don't think it matters if it includes
me or not I think what's important is
that free speech is the number one
weapon against absolute tyranny and
although you cannot have complete Free
Speech because then conversations
completely break down into asinine
insult fests I do like the idea of The
Changing of the Guard when it comes to
control over information is it possible
Andrew Tate to actually police something
like Twitter to to be a platform for
genuine Free Speech or is it so toxic
and tribal now that whatever happens you
know before we had all the people on the
right screaming away that there would be
no platformed and so on now you've got
all the people on the left screaming
that they're being no you know
diminished in some way uh it's it's very
tribal very toxic can musk cut through
that and if so how
yeah it's going to be extremely
difficult there's always going to be one
group of people who are extremely
unhappy but I think that anybody who's
perspicacious enough to understand the
truth of what's been going on in the
world recently will know that the left
and their narratives have certainly been
protected for a very long time and the
universe has swings and balances and God
often restores balance to the universe
and perhaps it might swing the other way
for a while I truthfully am a person who
believes that all points of view are
extremely important because as soon as
you block points of view you have
absolute tyranny I and in a way it's
sort of self-defeating isn't it because
you carried on getting huge attention it
was interesting to me that when you came
on the show for example we've had I
think nearly six million people have
viewed the whole interview that we did
which is a huge number of people
certainly far higher than Washington
conventional television so you have a
whole you have a whole world out there
online which operates away from social
media platforms
yeah uh I've been very very successful
in spite of them but not many people can
do that
I'm in a pretty unique position but I
think that everybody needs a voice to a
degree and social media platforms are
now the most important platforms on the
planet
they control information and they
influence real world decisions and they
influence people's perception of reality
the last few years of covet have been a
perfect example of what happens when you
censor one side of the argument and you
only allow one point of view to be
purported by the Matrix in and of itself
and that's how you end up in tyrannical
situations I think you were just
discussing that pierce yeah and I think
it's a perfectly valid point you know
people have quite I think quite rightly
held me to task over some of the
positions I took during the covert
pandemic notably when the scientists
said as a definitive fact that you you
couldn't transmit the virus if you had
the vaccine it turned out that wasn't
true and I based my observations on that
supposed fact and said right but in that
case if you refuse to be vaccinated you
shouldn't get the same rights as people
who've been vaccinated if if it's true
that if you're unjabbed you can pass it
on it turned out actually there's not
much difference whether you've been
vested in law and at that point I
changed my mind uh but I I felt that
there were a lot of people who were
being de-platformed from Twitter at the
time for questioning the validity of
scientific statements and they would
then be a complete U-turn so I do think
it was a very interesting period
actually for testing what Free Speech
was actually it was actually worse than
that you're right Pierce but it was
actually worse than interesting because
what happens is when you censor an
entire side of the argument and only
allowed one side of the argument to have
a voice you are changing reality in real
time you are shaping the world the only
reason that scam continued as long as it
did and the only reason people didn't
get to see their own parents get buried
and the only reason people sat and
masked missed cancer appointments
because they were scared of the common
cold was because they were censoring
anybody who said anything contrary to
the purported version of events that the
mainstream media decided they want the
entire world to swallow it's beyond
simply interesting and it's beyond
simply uh funny or coincidental yeah I
mean I will challenge you on one thing
it's not the common cold right covid-19
has killed 6.6 million people it is one
of the most deadly viruses certainly of
our lifetime so it wasn't the common
cold but I do think it is completely
Justified for people to say we should be
more cautious I think about accepting
during fast-moving pandemics the word of
scientists as being sacrosanct because
on a number of things from the use of
masks to the efficacy of vaccines in
preventing transmission they did massive
u-turns
I've read enough history books to know
that the people who do the censoring are
never the good guys and they've been
censoring a lot of arguments for a very
long time in the name of good they are
weaponizing virtue and it's always in
the name of tyranny anybody who is out
here trying to silence an entire side of
an argument on any subject whether it's
covid-19 immigration anything else they
are the evil people who are out for
absolute mind control of the populace I
certainly agree I certainly agree that I
think the healthiest thing for any
democracy is for All Views to be aired
and debated we seem to have lost the
ability to debate you know when I
interviewed you yeah we had a few
fractious moments but actually I thought
it was a pretty spirited debate between
people who perhaps had you know
preconceived views of each other and
I've got no problem interviewing you now
about this because I think you have an
interesting uh take on this stuff
and that's the key to life when you
reach that level of adolescence in your
mindset where you can't handle any point
of view that is contrary to your own
then you're truly a broken person and
that's what the internet is purporting
it's very interesting you said about
Twitter being tribal there's a large
contingent of people on Twitter who
simply cannot handle reading and opinion
which differs from their own and that is
a degree of immaturity that we do not
need adults to be functioning with in
the modern world no I agree if you're
Elon Musk this idea of charging eight
dollars now a month uh whatever it is to
access the Blue Tick premium Twitter
account would you do that would you pay
the extra
I think that social media companies for
a very long time have lived in an
absolute fantasy where they've printed
money from thin air by charging people
for pixels and they grew into these
large conglomerates with too many staff
sitting around doing nothing having
coffee breaks and Elon Musk is a
businessman he's walked into the office
and he's firing a bunch of people who
are messing around doing nothing and he
wants his business to make money as it
absolutely should and how he decides
that happens is his prerogative I don't
see why we should sit and accept that
our website needs 200 000 people sitting
around discussing in Long meetings
sitting on bean bags about policy of
human rights of some garbage when he's
come along and said no I'm a businessman
we're going to charge for our service
we're going to reduce the number of
Staff we're going to be a functional
coherent company as they should be and
that's his prerogative to do it as he's
bought the company I think he can do
whatever he wants yeah I mean I don't
disagree because I remember the
appalling censorship of the New York
Post exclusive about Hunter Biden the
son of the presidents about his laptop
this is three weeks before the election
that Joe Biden won he was heading you
know to a possible Victory but it was
tight and that story they reckon could
have ticked it either way but it was
completely suppressed and censored uh
starting with Twitter then Facebook then
others Twitter literally locked out the
New York Post account for two weeks for
breaking a completely true story I
thought that was shameful when
it's worse than shameful it's worse than
shameful when you control information
you control the real world they affect
the real world in absolute
in real time they are genuinely
affecting the reality people live in
they are not just a company they're not
just a social media platform it affects
absolutely every single person on the
planet when it changes who is elected I
don't want to comment specifically on
Hunter Biden or the laptop I would never
kill myself but I don't think it's fair
that they would hide certain key
information that close to an election
and the fact that they've done that was
done specifically to affect to affect
the world that we all live in and we all
have to suffer the consequences of those
things so to sit and say that these
companies can just do whatever they want
in their private Etc no free speech is
beyond important for democracy it's
important for the reality that we exist
under
Andrew Tate thank you for joining me I
appreciate it
thank you Frank
well Study Club I'll be talking protests
and bird life and feeling most
definitely unsensitive this is my kind
of Eco activist
there she is
the naked bird lady but there is more to
her than just the outfit it's actually a
very good protest and we'll explain why
plus reaction to tonight's big breaking
news with Gavin Williamson has resigned
fired uh yet again I'll be with my pack
to talk about that they weren't
expecting that to happen but now they do
they'll move like all my cat my packs
into game mode on Gavin Williamson
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
well big breaking news another Gavin
Williamson uh arguably the world's most
useless uh politician has now been fired
for the third time uh this is really
quite extraordinary he got knighted
after the first two sackings so
presumably he'll now be elevated to the
House of Lords for services to being
useless to the country uh Telegraph
reporting tonight that Williamson met
Richard sunac face to face in number 10
tonight offered his resignation rather
than be sacked out right yeah you were
fired mate again and you were fired
because you're a nasty piece of work as
well as being useless and the combo is
not great if you're going to be trying
to restore some pride into the country
Richard says another day another Scandal
and I'm sorry I've got a little sympathy
for Richie sunneck he should never have
brought him back oh completely I mean
he's this guy Gavin Williamson I
actually can't call him by the the title
that he's gone it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous but he was useless once and
fired useless twice and fired then given
a title yeah out of sync with no normal
process for reasons we don't understand
and haven't been informed and now he's
been fired again for uh for very
seriously saying he wants to Slit the
throats of his of his political enemies
allegations and I just think what on
Earth did sunac think he was doing
apparently he was told of these text
allegations and complaints before he
appoints him you have to wonder what is
it that Gavin Williamson had on Boris to
be United on all of it had on sunac well
he was doing and he's probably got stuff
on all of them and apparently he used to
often wield that threat now now
um Paula Ron Adrian this story coming
when it does as Kate McCann said you
couldn't be worse timing
for Rishi sudak for his new government
for the Brave New World of Purity and
calmness after all the drama and Scandal
he's right back in it he's right back in
it and this is a problem for Rishi he
told us that he was different didn't he
that was his very clear message when he
came and he said I'm going to be
different I'm all about bringing
Integrity back to this job and then
within seconds what we have is Boris
Johnson with picture by name Pinscher by
nature and now we have Rishi sunak with
Gavin Williamson and we've been told
we've actually forgotten the lettuce Liz
trust well right she was there so for
such a short period of time yeah I mean
talk about Scandal she tanked the pound
she sent interest rates soaring she
bankrupted probably millions of families
right and she's gone in 44 days and now
we have this and we have swella
who is there just hovering hovering why
is she there why did he bring her back
and that's not going to go away well we
know why don't we Richard I mean this
was all part of the big tent bringing
people that you need to bring in for
political expedience and also from all
parts of the party which is good
leadership if you're trying to unify
people particularly after a turbo
they've got to be the right people of
course they've got to be the right
people you've got to make the right
judgments and you can't stand on a
platform of integrity and then do a
complete u-turn on something you
campaigned on I uh Shale gas fracking
and then ditch it so he lied just like
he ditched Boris Johnson for lying so
that was appalling and now he's being
sussed for uh for his ridiculous
appointment of an utter failure I
wouldn't trust Gavin Williamson
literally to run a sweet shop without
expecting him to eat half the sweets and
throw the others if they were
hard-boiled at people standing next to
him he's that kind of guy right he takes
pride in being a vile Visa work but as a
journalist aren't you waiting for the
Gavin William tapes that must be because
I know about Matt Hancock's diary he's
trying to justify the indefensible one
I'll keep you out of that Richard but
the the uh the reality by Gavin
Williamson is he was always over
promoted and you've got to think that
he's got so much dirt on all these
people from because the chief whips soak
up all the dirt on everybody that's
their job right but if you get sacked
once you might just get given another
chance but if you get sacked twice why
on Earth would you give someone another
chance and reappoint them to the camera
I'm expecting him now to announce a book
deal and go to the jungle as the as the
new member of the Jungle to replace the
one that bailed I mean he's got his whip
hasn't he Williamson with his wit and
his torrential yeah
um
I went on to Ben Ferguson uh in America
about the American Midsummer Nations
crucially important tonight before we go
Tim
smug face he's the cat that's got the
cream because he knows that Red Wave is
coming look at him look at him uh before
we get to you Ferguson I'm going to get
a quick take on this from YouTube the
significance of this being probably if a
lot of Donald Trump's picks that he's
helped promote up the ladder for this
midterm election if they do well he's
going to come out he's already said next
Tuesday Mar-A-Lago I'm running all
singing all dancing Hill announces
running and in a sense that completely
kiboshes the chances of anybody else who
might want to run because he will say
the people want me I'm the success story
and I think the problem for the
Democrats is they've been useless Joe
Biden looks like he's literally half
dead I'm sorry to say that but he does
and Kamala Harris is number two is
completely ineffectual the problem is
the 6th of January which I cannot
believe anyone in America has forgotten
about yeah that is the problem problem
and that is what Trump will never be
able to get over thank you to you too
let's bring in Ben Ferguson um Ben I can
understand why you're looking so smug
um because I do think that the the Red
Wave is coming and the Republicans I
think they're going to take back not
just the house but also the Senate
yeah I look I think that I think you're
probably going to see it 53 maybe even
54. uh Senators that are Republican at
the end of the night tonight and I think
the messaging for conservatives was
really smart they talked the issues and
even Democratic strategists I've talked
to over the last couple days they said
look they screwed it up this White House
did not listen to the voters Democrats
didn't listen to the voters they tried
to make this election about Roe v Wade
people were caring about the economy
they were caring about inflation they
were caring about high gas prices uh and
when you just don't listen to voters you
get your AWS kicked on Election Day and
that's what's going to happen to a lot
of Democrats okay the one thing about
all this is that Trump clearly is going
to run again and you would think he may
have a a free run to becoming the
nominee and then a very good chance of
becoming president again which would be
an extraordinary comeback
um obviously he's got the legal issues
but he might feel this gives him a bit
of a protective shield if he becomes a
nominee but what about Ron DeSantis the
governor of Florida who I think has been
a rising star on the party for quite a
while now Trump has come out tonight on
Fox News I said I don't know if he's
running about DeSantis I think he could
really hurt himself badly I could tell
you things about him that won't be very
flattering and know more about him than
anybody other than perhaps his wife any
of that stuff is not good uh and he
called him Rhonda sanctimonious last
week he's goading the Santas and
DeSantis has shown no sign when anybody
else has come after him but backing down
are we going to see the big battle
finally that people have been waiting
for Trump be DeSantis for the soul of
the Republicans look
I I you know that DeSantis is looking at
this he's been obviously playing it very
smart in Florida he's very popular
Nationwide and I think there's two
things here that Donald Trump and I this
is me just talking as a political
consultant with that hat on he is
worried that DeSantis gets in and then
something happens if DeSantis gets in
appears the floodgates open and you will
see a lot of different people that will
jump in there's people talking about car
Lake there's people that are talking
about the new faces in the party from
this election and you'll have others
that I think clearly
is your money gonna take one is your
money on Trump not only running but
winning the nomination and the White
House again
look it I I think if you put him on a
debate stage with a bunch of other
Republicans it is going to change that
race dynamically the question is if you
run against Donald Trump and you beat
him can you get his supporters who will
be angry yeah to actually coalesce
around you as a nominee and that's going
to be the trickiest part for anybody
that challenges them because look this
guy filled stadiums he's still agree
he's still the most charismatic guy in
the whole field probably in World
politics Ben Ferguson yeah good to see
you I know it's a happy time for you
John we'll talk to you again later in
the week perhaps when when all this may
or may not have happened but I
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much
while lots of protesters really annoying
me at the moment but this one I'm
completely in favor of she's naked
painted I happen to add and will be
taking me under her Wing the bird woman
will be live to explain why she's doing
this and I'll be saying why I supporter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
well this show is called uncensored and
this is about as unscented as it gets
I've had harsh words of militant Eco
Warriors blocking Rose and gluing
themselves to prizes are in my view
they're incredibly irritating and
alienate any public support however I
had no such complaints about my next
guest who marched naked through London
painted in feathers to protest a decline
in birds as I said at the time I'm
definitely in favor of more birds well
bird girl Hannibal and Taylor joins me
now Hannah welcome to the program thank
you you are the most uncensored person
I've had on the show ruffling some
feathers why aren't you naked people
well I did hear your challenge but I
didn't think the public were quite ready
for that tell me very quickly what is
your protest about so the feather speech
campaign is science and artists coming
together to try to use
um common sense to save these amazing
Birds Swifts and three other red lips
listed species facing National
Extinction simple solution with the
petition but it needs a hundred thousand
signatures what's the answer the answer
is we can all help these Birds by
putting Swift bricks in our new house is
which is why I'm I have a petition which
is I I want you to sign it because I'm
going to be signing your petition but
also individual people can help these
Birds because the RSP be fully
supportive of this they think getting a
good thing and is it easy for people to
have brickwork which allows for these
nests for the the Swifts and so on to
exist yes the problem is we're actually
blocking their holes up naturally um so
we could stop doing that that would be
great and for new houses we could put
these little really easy bricks in and
hey Presto win-win humans closest Wild
neighbors they don't die out they're
amazing now you're on National
Television right now yeah barely wearing
a stitch of clothing this is mostly
paint I really love the birds honestly I
really do this takes guts to do this
right yeah I'm pretty nervous right now
to be honest what are you thinking as
you stand there I'm thinking I'm doing
this for the birds I can be I can be
public ridiculed judged whatever but I'm
actually doing it for the birds I'm
desperate for them what reaction have
you had from people to always mixed um
people are saying I'm brave I'm not I'm
desperate
um people are saying I'm stupid fine I'm
ridiculous but I'm actually just trying
to get this this voice for the birds
because they can't speak so I am
prepared I did go sort of naked once for
a commercial and I'm prepared to go back
to this look have you seen this all
right peers we've got two minutes what
do you think I think more feathers and
we're on to something you could really
help you've got eight million followers
on Twitter I need a hundred thousand
signatures debated them I've got like
five thousand no I'm gonna get those
numbers up because I actually think it's
a good cause we don't want the Swift to
go at it what are the other birds um
starlings how sparrows house Martins but
Swift they fly more time any in the air
than any other bird they come back to
our houses one epic thing three and no
problem with the tits no problem with
the tits no tits aren't really involved
in this apart from ironic Yeah ironic
yeah yeah yeah but it's made these
Swifts Swift's house sparrows I love
house and people think they're ordinary
in common they're not they're on the Red
List they're facing ninth National
Extinction with 70 British Birds that's
a lot here how do people sign the
petition they go on hannibalontaylor.com
they go on your Twitter yes
the least we can do for this lady for a
peaceful protest you're not daubing
graffiti anywhere you're not chucking
soup on Van goghs you're just doing this
you're coming up here's Morgan
uncensored as uncensored as any guest
has ever been I applaud the the the the
I think The Bravery of what you're doing
and I'm gonna is it this yeah no it's
not gonna be a Swift
that's it from us Keep It Uncensored
good night
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]